meeting has started
okay good evening and welcome to
tonight's
virtual planning meeting my name is
danny kendall i'll be
chairing tonight's meeting in accordance
with the rules and procedures is set out
in your um your agendas uh before we get
started if i could just run through a
little bit of housekeeping please uh
i think everyone's been made has been uh
given a copy of the council's guide to
etiquette and virtual meetings i'm just
going to run through the most important
points here if that's okay please ensure
your device is fully charged or is
charging throughout the meeting
um make sure you mute your microphones
when not speaking that goes for
everybody please
including me uh turn on the microphone
when addressing the committee
uh turn off the microphone again
immediately when you've finished talking
um if i could also ask people to
remember to switch their mobile devices
phones etc either turn them off or turn
them silent as well please that would be
very helpful
um quickly if any members of the
committee
should encounter some sort of connection
issue during the meeting
uh please try to rejoin if you can't
rejoin then that's fine
we will uh we'll treat it as if you have
left the meeting
and the meeting will proceed as normal
as long as it's quarant
um please be aware that of course for
members of the committee and indeed uh
public participants tonight and
all speakers that tonight's meeting is
being recorded
and of course live webcast images and
sound may be used for training purposes
in the future
um that's my bit of housekeeping out of
the way uh before the meeting started
just make
all members of public aware before
meeting started it was established that
uh every member of the committee can
see and hear the proceedings and of
course they have read
all the reports and the update sheet
um right we move on to introducing
the officers so if i read out your first
name
would you uh reply with your name and
role in the meeting tonight please
officers
uh we'll start then please with olivia
olivia quinn democratic services
thank you um mesa
mason nash legal services uh except for
the biddeford application
chair which ross chambers will be the
legal officer
thank you ross we don't need you to
introduce yourself now thank you mason
for you dale barker please
dale bark team leader senior planners
and conservation
thank you uh alice
alex costner planning officer thank you
stuart
stuart florthy planning officer thanks
and louise
louise casey planning officer wonderful
thank you officers
much appreciated um final uh reminder
please for the committee uh members
committee when we do get to voting
um we'll do that by a roll call as
normal um
please say your name followed by clearly
for against or abstain
and just a final uh thing to remember
uh if any members of the committee wish
to uh speak in the meeting please
indicate in the chat
box on the right hand side and uh use
that
for that purpose only right housekeeping
out the way
let's move to uh item one of our agenda
which is apologies for absence please
chad we've got no apologies thank you
very much
item two is disclosure of interests uh
i'll kick that off if that's okay uh
item four on tonight's agenda i received
an
email i either yesterday or the day
before with some photographs just to
make
members of committee aware um any other
members of the committee received that i
think a couple of others did
so if we if we log that as all members
of the committee receiving that that's
good
uh my second uh disclosure of interest
is in item 10.
although it reads in the in the uh
committee report as being in councillor
paris ward it's actually
in my ward so i will step down for item
10
um on the agenda and uh councillor
richards will uh step in and cheer for
me on that one
okay um so councillor eden
you have a declaration of interest uh
it's not strictly a declaration of
interest chair it's
for transparency purposes i've checked
with legal uh
it's only around the fact that i work
down to this bridge road so items
three i have a sort of transparency
thing to announce that's all should i
like entering with an open mind
that makes perfect sense thank you
councillor that's lovely um
then uh counselor adam please um
chair you already addressed it with um
the email that we received on
uh item four thank you thank you very
much councillor adam
we'll love that as having been the
entire committee uh councillor parry
counselor perry sorry chair it was just
the
uh email i'd received regarding the
bidford application
okay okay thank you very much
um council richards
thank you chair um application 1902 585
um out uh the item number three um
historically i've been involved in
various meetings and events relating to
this
application in my capacity as a cabinet
member at that time
um i have spoken to our management
officers to confirm that he is happy
that i continue
uh with an open mind um on this uh
and continue with the debate and remain
on the committee i'm happy i'm here with
an open mind
he said he is clear to me uh that i'm
okay to continue so i will continue but
i wanted to let you know for
transparency reasons
thank you council rich as much
appreciated um yes mason ash please
legal
you have final declaration as well
mesa
mason ash
sorry jay what happened if i actually
i'll meet myself to apologize
uh just to confirm i have a conflict of
interest with item number four and we'll
be stepping down as the legal officer
and ross chambers will be taking over
for that item
that's wonderful thank you mesa lovely
stuff um
dale i we've discussed it before the
meeting uh and in my chairman's briefing
we're going to make a couple of changes
to the running order tonight
just for ease of use it just makes more
sense it'll flow a bit better
dale would like to talk about that for a
second
yes thank you chair um we put great
effort into
making this order of uh the agenda
legible and we weren't terribly
successful
so for clarity what we're intending to
do tonight
is to deal with item number three
followed by item number four
followed by item number 10 because they
are similar items and
all will become clear during the process
then items 5 and 6 are identical reports
dealing with applications 970 and 886
that's the order we'll deal with them
971st and then 886
and then the remaining three items seven
eight and nine
are all for applications are for
applications 480
481 and 482 and again we'll deal with
them
in that order does that make sense jeff
thank you i think so that's wonderful
thank you dale i'm sure we'll work it
out to go along if you have any issues
but it makes sense to me so that's
something at least um right um
that's all the declarations of interest
out the way we've looked at the
running order so without further ado we
can move to our first um
application this evening uh this is
item three found on page one of your
report and the application reference is
nineteen slash zero two five eight
five slash out and this is land at
timothy's bridge road stratford upon
avon
i'm not gonna read the entire
description of the development i think
i'll instead hand that over to the
presenting officer
alex koznet alice over to you
thank you chairman and i'm just going to
share my screen so i'll just check that
you can see
that bear with me one moment
making everyone see that all good here
lovely thank you for confirming that
thank you chairman the application site
as identified by the black dot in the
centre of the plan is located in
stratford-upon-avon's built-up area
boundary
the application site forms part of a
wider area of land which is
allocated for a residential-led
mixed-use development under proposal
sua1 of the core strategy
and ssb-1 of the stratford ndp
and is termed the canal quarter
regeneration zone
this slide shows the land allocated and
a proposal sua1
outlined in black with the canal in blue
and railway line in purple
and the application site in red
the application before members this
evening is a hybrid planning application
which seeks
part full and part outline consent the
application
site is outlined in red with the full
element outlined in black
the canal again is identified by the
blue line and the railway by the purple
dash line
planning permission is sought for up to
500 dwellings across the entirety of the
site with 56 provided and an apartment
block located in the full
area the remaining 444 dwellings will be
located across the outlying area
there is also scope within the
application area sorry with an outline
area
for a residential institution falling
within use class c2
either in the form of a care home or an
extra care scheme
a total of 1625
square meters of commercial floor space
is proposed across the entire site
with 217 square meters of commercial
floor space within the full element
the full element also comprises an area
of public open space and amended
priority junction to timothy's bridge
road
the outline element is all matters
reserved except for means of access
this slide shows the layout for the full
element with building a
providing the commercial space at ground
and lower ground floor levels
underground parking at lower ground
floor level and 56 apartments
an area of public open space termed
timothy's bridge green and new priority
junction on timothy's bridge road is
also proposed in full
this slide shows the east and west
elevations of building a
the building proposed within full
element the west elevation shows the
lower ground floor level parking
and this slide shows the north and south
elevations of building a
the south elevation would front onto the
canal beyond the towpath and strip of
pos
this slide shows a visualization of the
full element comprising building a
and timothy's bridge green building a
would be constructed in red brick with
rough brick detailing and dark gray
cladding
the roof would be finished with slate
tiles and would incorporate
pv panels here is the illustrative
master plan that has been provided
building a and pos are proposed in full
so just to remind members it's in in
this area here
with the remainder shown for
illustrative purposes only at this stage
taller development would be located
around timothy's bridge green and at
building b
at the southeast corner of the site
there is the opportunity for morgan
syndal to be
retained and re-classed so that's that
large building there i've got a photo
later on in the presentation
so this will be confirmed through future
reserve matters with two and three story
dwellings across the remainder of the
site so around this area here
this plan shows the parameters in
respect of building heights
the highest area denoted by dark blue
would have an
aod so above ordinance datum of plus 72
and just to put that into context the
height of the existing morgan sindle
building so that was what i was
referring to a moment ago
has a maximum aod of 73.54 and the
section at the bottom of the plan
shows the outline of the morgan single
building in orange and the existing
warehouses on site in blue
and then the illustrative buildings
proposed through this outline
application
this plan shows the maximum extent of
development the green areas denote pos
which includes an 11 meter wide strip of
pos
adjacent to the canal which would form a
canal side park
just to take you through some photos
this is looking in a south easterly
direction down timothy's bridge road
the application site is in the distance
and morgan syndal can be seen as a
marker to the site
closer to the site still looking down
timothy's bridge road in a south
easterly direction morgan syndal can be
seen beyond the group of trees
here we are looking down timothy's
bridge road in a north westerly
direction
the existing road layout can be seen as
proposed the giveaway would change
locations so you can see the giveaways
here at the moment and it would
basically be moved
to be along there
here we are looking in a southerly
direction towards mason's road the
location of the full element phase one
is to the left of the photo
and at the other end on mason's road
looking up timothy's bridge road toward
the application
site this is just a couple of photos
which have been taken from the existing
canal towpath which adjoins the site
and then this final photo is taken from
the royal shakespeare theatre viewing
tower
i've tried to identify morgan cinder
which you can just see in the distance
there as a marker for the location of
the application
site chairman the recommendation is to
grant this hybrid application in
accordance with the recommendation
detailed in the committee agenda
along with the additional two conditions
included on the update sheet
thank you chairman
that's great thank you alice excellent
presentation lovely stuff
um so we go to our first speaker um
this is uh from the town council traffic
town council
uh councillor ian fragi hey elsa fragile
do we have you on the line
cancer fragile if you press star six to
a mute
we'll give cancer fragile just one more
moment
move on to the next speaker
we can hear you um
thank you welcome to the meeting um you
know the process of course you've got
three minutes at the end of that three
minutes don't don't
uh leave the uh meeting we may have
questions for you and we'll give you a
warning at 10 seconds if that's okay
okay yes
a few years ago i was invited to a
workshop at venture house
to look at possible proposals for the
development of the canal quarter
regeneration zone
where we were shown possible examples
which were aspirational
and potentially capable of winning
design awards for stratford
and become a sought after place to visit
as well as to live
this was later followed up by sdc doing
a presentation the possibilities
possibilities of
town council meeting so i'm afraid that
the town council
are most disappointed with this first
offering
for the canal four quarter regeneration
is running short of being considered
aspirational and award-winning as an
example
uh policy fsb one of the ndp
neighborhood plan restricts the height
to no more than four stories
unless there is a specific and clear
justification for being taller
this plan originally had eight stories
which admittedly were reduced to six
but with no clear justification as to
why it is
is still taller than four the town
council understand
or understood that the canal quarter
would be around 650 homes
spread throughout the whole quarter
however this application
indicates around 500 homes on 20
25 percent of the canal quarter site
which implies that the remaining 150
homes
would be spread on 75 of the site
unless of course the plan has been
changed to accommodate more than 650
across the canal quarter in its entirety
the time council would request that this
application be deferred
so that made can be consulted to give
their expert device
design advice to ensure the canal
quarter
attains the quality which was originally
envisaged
thank you
thank you councillor fragile um do you
have any questions from the committee
for the town council please indicate in
the chat
give it one second longer
right i think i think there are no
questions councillor franchi thank you
very much for your time tonight so much
appreciated
all right thank you thank you bye-bye
okay we move to our next speaker uh mr
william rimmel please
mr rimmel quick reminder i think star
six to unmute yourself
chairman it looks like he's still in the
meeting
thank you thank you caroline thanks mr
rimmel can you have another girl
i'm trying to find out can you hear me
oh we've got you wonderful stuff
thank you and everybody can hear you um
right okay mr rubble
same rules apply you have three minutes
thank you for waiting by the way
um don't leave the meeting immediately
at the end of your of your time
we'll give you uh 10 seconds um warning
before the end of your three minutes
thank you over to you sir
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to address planning
committee this evening
uh to say my name is will reimal i'm
development director for st
joseph which is the division of the
partly group and we are the applicants
we're really excited to be at the
forefront of the regeneration of the
canal quarter with our proposed
development
at timothy bridge road swan's landing
represents a fantastic opportunity
to further enhance the existing
community at one of
stratford-upon-avon's most sustainable
development sites
as a key part of the delivery of
stratford's core strategy
neighborhood plan and the canal call to
spd we undertook extensive engagement
with the local community and key
stakeholders prior to the submission of
this application
this helped us to understand their wants
and needs and has been reflected in our
proposals
throughout the planning process we have
all worked closely with the development
with the planning department and their
consultants
we've actively responded to comments and
have collaboratively
collaboratively arrived at a scheme
which we feel is fantastic for existing
and future residents
the application site forms part of a
wider allocation for the regeneration of
brownfield land
to deliver a range of uses including
residential office and associated
leisure
the application before you this evening
seeks planning approval to 500
residential units
with an option to also include some
extra care units
as part of this application we also seek
detailed approval for 56 homes
969 square meters of flexible commercial
space
and public publicly accessible open
space for new and existing residents
which represents phase one of the right
wider proposals i think it is only right
that i mention affordable housing at
this juncture
as it sets out in the committee report
the independently assessed financial
viability shows the scheme is unviable
should any affordable housing be
provided we have however taken a
long-term view
based on our confidence in the product
we can deliver and offer 15 units at 60
discount market value which we hope will
be well received
if we gain approval swans landing will
make a considerable contribution to the
local economy
both in the short term during the
construction phase and long term through
estate management and the provision of
the commercial floor space
as alluded to within the committee
report the impact of covert 19 on the
entire nation is acute
should planning permission be granted
we'd be looking to start on site as soon
as practically possible
bringing a considerable investment and
show of commitment to the local area
which i think should be wholeheartedly
welcomed
to conclude it is our view that the
proposals at swan's landing
would raise the overall profile of the
wider regeneration area
and act as a catalyst for the future
prosperity of the canal quarter
this is an exciting first step in the
canal quarters regeneration
and we look forward to delivering it
with your support thank you for your
time and i'll be happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much mr rival um much
appreciated uh we have one question uh
so far councillor parry
thank you chair and um okay good evening
mr remember
you mentioned um in your in your
presentation
that if we were minded to grant planning
permission this evening
um you would hope to start as soon as or
as practically possible could you just
give us some
indication of when that that
that would be obviously within the in
the three years
just a question yeah no certainly so
it's
it's something that we've we've spent a
lot of time looking into not least
in the current economic climate
our our construction teams are are
looking into a starting site
as early as sort of q2 next year which
which we're currently thinking about
may time but i hope you all appreciate
that um
until we get hopefully get planning
permission we can't sort of crystallize
that
yeah totally understand thank you
thank you for that uh now councillor
adam please thank you chairman
um i was wondering if you could um just
explain the process by which you've
reached the numbers considering the the
lack of affordable housing that you've
proposed
are there other schemes that have uh
that could have been considered within
your proposal
to allow this to include them and remain
viable or was that not considered as
part of your
submission
there was a detailed there was a
detailed design process that
we went through with our with our
architects and the wider design team
um there's a there's a fine there is a
balance as you can appreciate between
the numbers
of um of residential units and it's an
opportunity
it's a number within the allocation of
the canal quarter
um but it also comes back to what we
feel is appropriate
for um this regeneration sites
um once we arrived at those those
numbers then there is a process of
financial viability which i'm sure
you're
familiar with um which meant
that we were unable to provide any
affordable housing
in terms of strict liability terms but
as i alluded to we've got confidence in
what we can produce
and therefore as documented within the
committee report and the update sheet we
have made
a an offer of affordable housing
notwithstanding the financial viability
thank you very much uh good answers so
um just making sure there weren't any
further questions i don't think we do
mr rymel thank you very much for your
time tonight much appreciated
thank you thank you um
we moved then we don't have a speaker
registered counselor cleve
wanted um can't be here tonight um as
ward member
but wanted me to make sure that i drew
your attention to the fact that uh
we received a an objection uh from a
ward member
um and of course if i could just draw
your attention to the details
that are in the report of course to
outline the objection there
so uh that done you can move to our
points of clarification from the
oh hang on sorry yes okay we're straight
on to that apologies yes
uh tony dixon council dixon very quick
off the mark first point of
clarification go for it
uh thank you chairman alice there are
on page 40 41 lists
of uh the following contributions
obligations have come
forward um essentially there's quite a
total there within the report i'm just
wondering if
we should be giving any weight to any of
those requests
given the financial viability of
this this development because it could
be that if these funds
you know are not forthcoming are not
available
and indeed that is certainly a
possibility that it will not all be for
coming
forward exactly how we should uh regard
this application in respect of that and
is and also if i may ask during the
presentation or during the
reading the report i concluded that
there was a
request for good access to the canal
towpath and i just wondered if you can
identify on the plans
where it is hoped such can be i'm
assuming it is
in the area where it's going to be
reserved to matters
etc um but certainly it wasn't covered
and i just wondered if you could uh
please clarify that for me thank you
yes of course thank you and so in
relation to the developer contributions
which are listed on page 14 and 41
just to clarify because of the viability
position of the scheme
none of those contributions are being
made because the scheme would be
unviable
if they were to be collected by a 106.
um
so when you sort of ask how much weight
you should give to that i've then gone
on to
basically consider that in the planning
balance and identify that there is
inevitably going to be harm
because we're not collecting the
financial contributions that
infrastructure
providers have requested off the back of
the development proposed
so just to clarify we're not collecting
those because of the viability position
we are however collecting the the
community infrastructure um levy charge
so that would be as normal the details
of that are provided
on the update sheet so that will go
towards funding infrastructure within
the area
um but at this stage i can't confirm
where that money will go
um we have an infrastructure funding
statement which identifies projects for
still money to be spent on
um but like i say at this point we can't
say for definite where that's going
um does that answer your first question
yes so in terms of the second question
and the
top links so if i uh share my screen so
i think you wanted to just see a plan
so bear with me one moment while i just
do that
so can you see oh no
bear with me
can you see the access and movement
parameters plan yes i can see it
brilliant so
um essentially this existing
towpath link um is to be retained and
and will be improved through the
development
the issue with the other links um is
that we would fully expect there to be a
lot of public access between the the
towpath
and the development and there is
identified this 11 meter strip as a
canal side park
along the canal frontage where it where
the application site does front onto it
so obviously excludes this area here and
we would expect many more connections
the reason why they haven't been put
formally in at the moment is because
they rely on agreement from third-party
land
are you the canal and river trust and st
joseph don't have the legals in place to
be able to confirm exactly
where those connections would be but
you're quite right they would come
through forthcoming reserve matters
and you will note that recommended
condition 30
um also ties that off just to make sure
that that level of information is
provided on future reserve matters for
areas
of the site which do adjoin the canal
tow path
thank you alice uh next question
councillor parry
thank you chair um alice i just wonder
whether you could
advise what's the situation normally
when we have
new development these days um as part of
the condition
we are um wishing to see
um fibre broadband delivered to
the development site what's the
situation with regard
to that um is that is that just
considered normal
is it or or do we need to have a special
mention as far as a condition is
concerned
i would fully expect it would be
provided as as of course because i know
that joseph a
very high quality developer but that
being said it's certainly something we
can add on as a condition to ensure that
it is
it is secured um
if if i can come through you that would
be um
i if we are minded to to go with grant i
think we should
certainly have that as a condition that
um fibre broadband is delivered to
all the um units that are proposed
thank you councillor parry um alice if
you want to make a note of that for now
uh if anybody wants to dissent against
that later on we'll come back to that in
the debate
um next question uh councillor jennings
please
thank you chair um the town council
um raised the question about the design
the urban design principles how's that
how is that being assessed
yes so uh just so you're aware when the
um canal quarter
was being allocated we undertook some
urban design analysis
and uh we got a urban design consultant
built form resource
involved in that process um so full
consistency
and to make sure that we were going to
achieve the high level of development
high quality development we were
expecting to come forward here
we again engaged with built form
resource through this application
so um they obviously know the site very
well from doing the urban design
analysis so from the preamp stage
um we instructed them to assist us in
determining the urban design impacts of
the
um of the application and the assessment
of of the urban design consultant is
provided at pages 32 and 33 of the
agenda
and basically the summary is that the
height massing bulk of building a is
considered to be acceptable
uh noting the town council objections
and the contents of the ndp but it's all
to do
with um three reasons are provided on on
page 33 of the agenda for why
that is acceptable and it basically
comes down to the the very large
buildings which are on site at the
moment
the larger spaces which will be around
the buildings to make sure that they
enclose those public spaces so obviously
we've got building a right next to
the pos so to have a larger building
will frame that pos
and similarly provide a landmark for the
site um
so so in conclusion although we haven't
gone to to made as
councillor fragile uh has alluded to or
suggested that we should do
we have engaged with an urban design
consultant who knows the site very well
excellent thank you very much thank you
and uh
final question council adam please
thank you um i note on
affordable housing um i know there's a
clause within uh cs18 that allows
uh viability assessments to to reduce
the amount
um and then you go on to mention the
mppf uh in
uh reference to reuse of brownfield land
which again talks about reducing um
affordable housing by a proportionate
amount can you just let me know what
that's proportionate to
um is that based on the violence here is
that based on the brownfield
sites being redeveloped
i i don't think it clarifies in the mppf
exactly what it means by proportionate
amount so i can only assume
that it's proportionate off the back of
the results of the viability work which
is done
so just follow up on that then so is
that area of the npppf
um does that reference viability at that
stage or is that only
referenced within our course strategy
sorry i don't think i understand the
question
um just said so obviously we're using
viability as a justification for
reduction in affordable housing
under our core strategy 18. yeah but
then
obviously being a different document the
mppf
um that's a separate reference so i'm
just wondering how those are meant to be
connected
and what metric we we can use to sort of
link
the reuse of brownfield sites to the
viabilities
you see what i mean john
careful do you have any comments on that
um good evening committee um john kaeper
policy manager
um councillor are you referring to
paragraph 63 of the
mpps that's correct yes yeah um
so just for members of the committee so
this says
provision affordable housing should not
be sold for residential developments
than non-major
to support reuse so i'm paraphrasing to
support the reuse of bradford land
where vacant buildings are being reused
or redeveloped any affordable housing
contribution
due should be reduced by proportionate
amounts
um so this is equivalent to the gross
law space
again this this this paragraph i
understand
um originated from the
desire by the government to impose a
sort of standard
nationwide threshold for housing so i
think that's where this
this comes from um and that is uh
sort of less than uh 10 units um i think
the
the point that i think alice is is
trying to make is the
we have a brownfield site here and the
mppf as a whole
when you when you read the the document
um
certainly does encourage brownfield use
and reuse
um because it's it's a better use of
land
and it's more efficient and effective
and
particularly when they're within town uh
existing towns
it's better to build here than on
greenfield sites on the edge
so it's it's just trying to reference
that point i think counselors
the the reference to cs18 again that's
consistent with
the mppf and other paragraphs but
again the starting point is we should be
providing affordable housing on site
however if the um
the viability assessment shows that
that's not viable then um in those cases
when we're satisfied that's the case
using the the methodology then
we do allow um such schemes to come
forward without affordable housing so
it's just trying to um i think uh make
those two points
i hope that's helpful chairman thank you
thank you thank you
that's great thanks john um okay uh
positive clarification counselor parry
thank you chairman i just wanted further
clarification on
obviously this site because it was
highlighted or the
the site was highlighted in the call
strategy that was adopted in
2016 um would i be right in thinking
that
or and what i'm trying to get is how
many
how many years have you been has has the
planning team been working on
honing um shall we say this this
application
and um engaging with the developers
to ensure that whatever was put forward
here now is is the result of a of a
number
and series of amendments i'd just just
like to get a bit of a feel for
how many years the planning team has
been working
with the applicant yes of course i mean
in terms of development management
i'm sure the discussions policy-wise be
going up
much longer but in terms of development
management the pre-application
submission was formally made in may
2018.
so there would have been provisional
discussions before then but
the formal submission was made in may
2018 and i've been involved through the
whole of that through all of the pre-op
discussions and obviously
the the application stage and there's
probably been circa
ten amendments made to the scheme over
that time so
and i've been involved in um a lot of
meetings with town councils and
councillors and and virtual meetings
with them since lockdown
um so i can confirm that they have
sought to address
um as many of our concerns as possible
and to engage with local people
to try and overcome those concerns i
think that that's definitely fair to say
thank you alice um i noticed the chat is
quiet so i don't seem to be any further
points of clarification
um i think in that case committee should
we move to the debate
would anybody like to start the debate
on this uh application
council of harry thank you over to you
thank you chairman i i'd first just like
to say
that um what an excellent presentation
alice that you've delivered it
it really added a lot of color um having
spent
several hours over the weekend and last
night going through the committee report
um the report seemed to come to light
with you
to life with your presentation and all
the diagrams so thank you for that it's
really really helpful um
obviously we've it this is a very large
application
um i think at the end of the day
you know that clearly has been some very
close
and good engagement with the town
council
and local residents um i think it's
great that the
stories that the height of the the
highest building has come down from its
original eight stories um
i was also pleased to see that the sill
payment is over one million pounds
whilst the affordable housing is a very
low sum because stratfor town council
has an adopted neighborhood development
plan
they are going if we were minded to
approve this
they would receive nearly 300 000
pounds which is a sizable sum that would
obviously add to i believe their current
reserves are around
sort of 825 000 so i appreciate they've
got a
an issue on affordable housing but
obviously with that sort of size of
payment
they could actually even if we were to
approve it
invest in the acquisition of an
apartment or two perhaps
um to boost the affordable housing need
and their own investment bank
but looking at it i actually thought the
design
um and i take counselor fragile's point
that
he felt it was aspirational but i
actually feel it's the location which is
so
aspirational overlooking the canal
um the views from those apartments will
be just
absolutely stunning um and
i can see no material planning reason
um even on the numbers side because of
of planning policy to refuse this and i
would be very happy to step forward
and propose that we grant
application this application
planning permission i think that's all i
have to say thank you chair
councillor parry thank you very much for
what you've said there i i think you've
said
absolutely everything that was going
through my head on this application
absolutely everything
um i'm going to run through these
speakers uh so we've got
i noticed councillor richard wants to
second that he's the first to say that
so we'll come to him in a second
but we'll run through uh council
jennings first please capture jennings
yeah and i was going to say and the
economic impact of this
will bring considerable benefits and
that's a certain
material consideration um as far as the
urban design here i i think is
absolutely marvelous i mean
i think it's very impressive i think
it's been very well thought out
um very impressed with the presentation
and i'm
more than happy to go zomba councillor
richardson second hit first
oh well i don't know what the procedure
is on this i'm going to let you do it
because
unfortunately council hasn't verbally
said it so there we are so
it is proposed and seconded sorry peter
um right we'll then go to councillor
eden
thank you chair um i agree
uh entirely with the the full part of
the application
i do i do think that looks stunning um
i do still have massive concerns about
the 500 houses in the quarter of the
space that is really grating on me as
part of the outline
um planning though um you know
giving that the opportunity to that
entire site to
potentially be opened up to i don't know
1500 or 2000 houses that's
if it were to come about to search for
the remaining
parcels i'm a little bit on the fence on
the outline side of things
but the full side 100 support
and i will point out to you counselor
and of course the two applications come
together the full
and the outline it's one hand to the
other but
i'm sure you know that um we moved next
speak
well of course councillor richards you
did try to second it council jennings
beat you
do you want to add another thing i think
uh we can leave with that to be honest
chair and move straight to a vote
thank you um just um because he's
indicated council adam
thank you chairman um i think the work
that's been
put into this is is very good and the
design
of the scheme looks um you know in
keeping with the sort of development
that stratford
is looking for um
and i think the reuse of that brownfield
site is absolutely a good thing and it
should be
should be done i do have serious
concerns about the lack of affordable
housing though
um we're talking about sort of the
reduction from 35 percent to 3
now i know that the viability of of that
is of the
developer is a significant aspect of
that
under our own core strategies but i'm
very skeptical as to whether 500 houses
on a site that was um
pegged for well based on a quarter of it
162 and a half
um even if that is a guide um and
then not including any affordable
housing um
i'm not sure how that represents
sustainable development
um and i don't feel that that's meeting
the need of of the district
uh in in doing so um
like i say i think development of this
site is very good i think the
economic impact that that would have is
good and i don't object to
this development uh in those principles
but i think the density of it um
and the lack of affordable housing is a
red line for me that i i think does go
against
um our principles and of development and
i think i've got a real
issue with that um based on what the
other counselors have said i don't think
it will do much good but on that basis
i'd like to propose
refusing the application against the
officer's recommendation um
based on cs18
not not uh in reduction of affordable
housing not
representing sustainable developments if
i could come in there
we do have a proposition and it's been
seconded i'm gonna have to go to that
one
first if that's okay if that falls then
we can go to your
then we'll go to an alternative
proposition which would probably be
yours
um i believe i'm right on that one so
that we follow that procedure that
process
is uh yes sir thank you thank you
okay i appreciate that thank you thank
you and i do really appreciate
everything that's been said in terms of
the the development and the work that
the officers have put in
thank you council thank you um right i
think
we're ready to go to a vote on this
unless anybody else wants to jump in but
i think we're okay
um i'm presuming that everybody is happy
with the addition of the
uh fiber broadband uh that was proposed
earlier on by um
councillor parry uh no one said there
anything against it so
alice if we assume that's added as well
please
um so let's let's do this and just make
sure i'm not missing anything in the
update sheet we need to mention i don't
think so
um right so the proposition has been
proposed by councillor perry
and seconded by councillor jennings uh
that we approve
this application um i'll start us off
then we'll go to the roll call
councillor kendall
four councillor richards
councillor richard's four
councillor adam
councillor adam against councillor dixon
councillor dixon iv
iv chair that's six four and two against
thank you olivia excellent stuff uh
therefore the committee resolves to
grant
application reference 1902585 slash
o ut um olivia or or caroline do we need
to take a five minute break to bring in
the speakers for the next application
speak the speaker's ready chairman in
the lobby
in that case that's brilliant we can
move straight to our item number four
our agenda
uh then uh this is uh item four found on
page 47
and this is application reference twenty
slash
zero zero seven one one slash ful
big meadow honey born road [ __ ] on
haven
and it's the installation of a cctv
camera
onto a cctv column proposed to be
installed
10 meters above the ground level stuart
is
stuart flaherty you are the presenting
officer
over to you thank you chairman good
evening everybody um
i've just shared my screen can i just
confirm that people can see
uh the presentation on your screen right
now i can see it perfectly thank you
perfect
thank you chairman um thank you good
evening
um tonight i'm going to present two full
planning applications for cctv cameras
uh mounted on dedicated cctv columns
this is essentially what they will look
like in what is a mocked up image
they are proposed in two locations one
in bibliomaven
and one in wellsborne both involve
cameras and columns
of the same design in each case the
camera will look like this and will be
mounted on a pole
either of eight meters in height or 10
meters in height in this
instance here in biddeford at the first
application here at big meadow
in biddeford um this is a cctv camera as
you can see
um and you can see that there is
something of a level change in that this
is actually proposed behind the bridge
um to the pedestrian footpath here
actually on the bridge itself
um there is also then a small snippet of
what are the
equipment specifications and what the
camera will be
um here we now see
uh location of the column itself
signified by the red
dot uh we are sighted within a
conservation area as signified by the
purple line
um we can all one can also see that
we're near the river raven
uh and next to both a scheduled engine
monument and a grade one listed bridge
the biddeford bridge as signified here
in red
this proposal will help to enhance
facilities and provide sizeable public
benefits in a prominent riverside
location
there is a desire from the local
community to have these enhanced
security measures in place
in this popular recreational area and
this is reflected in support from the
parish council
chairman the recommendation is for
approval subject to the conditions shown
on page
52 of your report thank you
perfect thank you stuart excellent stuff
um we moved to our first speaker
ian died co-chair bifford
ivan cricket club please objecting are
you on the line sir
hi there everybody hear me yes perfect
thank you can hear you very clearly
um you have three minutes please stay on
the line at the end of that time just in
case we have any questions for you
and we'll give you a warning bell at uh
10 seconds if that's okay
lovely thank you that's right uh so
first of all i'd like to uh
to uh confirm the support of bible
cricket club in supporting the parish
council's wish to have a
cctv at the big meadow
as the parish council is aware and is
noted in the report that the sports
pavilion on bigfoot
big meadow used by the local junior
football club and the cricket club has
suffered break-ins and vandalism
over the years due to its location
in addition other parts of the big
meadow around the building and the outer
parts of the meadow have also
suffered from antisocial behavior
the proposal i believe is to place the
camera at the entrance to the big meadow
however the report i don't believe has
gone into the detail about the coverage
of of the said camera or the clarity of
the coverage and how much detail of the
meadow will be captured by this camera
one part of the meadow which will not be
captured for the majority of the year
will be the sports pavilion
because of the tree foliage and the
other newer trees
from the entrance down to the
sports pavilion and the
parish council toilets that will block
the line of sight for the proposed cctv
camera
i've sent a picture to the capsules
confirming this point
as you will note from the second photo
sent to the councillors the sports
pavilion has just undergone a
refurbishment costing thousands of
pounds
however without the protection of cctv
it will be susceptible to further
anti-social behavior
in the future at bitter curriculum
we believe a better positioning of the
cctv
camera further into the big meadow would
capture
more of the big meadow and and other
issues
um furthermore there is already a cctv
camera on the other side of the meadow
situated that's rock and ball rush
which captures the entrance to the car
park the bridge
and the the the first part of the big
meadow
and i'm sure this could already be
utilized and viewed if needed
in conclusion as the report is not clear
on the coverage
and clarity of the cctv camera
for certain parts of the meadow like the
sports pavilion
are not within the sight line of the
saying the cricket club does not agree
that the proposal ensures that the
safety and well-being of the visitors
will positively reduce his crime or fear
of the crime
as the report states i would therefore
ask a committee to refuse the
application
with a hope district and parish
councillors
agree to a more appropriate and
beneficial position
for the cctv camera and the big weather
in the future to ensure the safety and
well-being of visitors together with the
reduction of
of the fear of crying whilst people are
enjoying the big meadow
thank you
excellent timing thank you very much um
do we have any questions from the
committee
council jennings
chair thank you just a quick one uh if
you just
the question is if you just spent a lot
of money just doing up
the pavilion why didn't you put some
cctv cameras out
because to to to actually guard the
pavilion
the the camera needs to be away from the
pavilion in order to
to to look towards it and we were aware
of this proposal
for the cctv commit coming in because it
was part of the
neighborhood development plan that was
issued at christmas
okay thank you okay thank you uh and
there's no other questions popping up in
the chat
so in which case mr died thank you very
much for your time tonight much
appreciated thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
thank you
um okay we don't have any other speakers
on this application so we move straight
to points of clarification
um can i start that one off stuart is
that okay
oh hang on i apologize um
councillor pemberton as ward member i
don't have down
council pemberson has registered to
speak tonight
um he has put something in the chat he i
believe he's in full support of the
application um
so i'll leave it at that if that's okay
council pemberton uh in terms of points
of clarification
um stuart only one question what was the
level of consultation
um between the applicant and
the and the parish council in this case
in terms of the positioning of this
camera
and why was this um location chosen
uh thank you chairman um there is a
consultation document published
on the application file um there was a
period of consultation between the
applicants
and uh the local uh community that
included the parish
in addition um as is reflected on your
update
sheet um i was sent a updated
consultation response that
was taken undertaken during the lifetime
of this application uh where the
applicant took it upon themselves to do
a further round of consultations and
that's available to you on your public
file
um there is um
[Music]
mr the comments notwithstanding there is
a large groundswell of
local support it would appear for this
notwithstanding objection made by the
gentleman just now but
um that is my understanding of what's
taking place between the applicants and
members of the local community
well that's fine thank you stuart i
appreciate that uh next question
council harry thank you jay um
you stole my thunder i was going to ask
exactly the same question
thank you councillor parry uh another no
other points clarification being raised
i think in the in the chat so
debate we're about to start off
cool council jennings
okay and i think these days then cameras
are
a part and parcel of the modern
landscape some may find them
objectionable but uh
i always feel that the benefits outweigh
any any negatives on this
um there seem to be
the thing which may may be beneficial is
having more of them
perhaps um but then again that can be a
something for the future and i think uh
i i'm sort of struggling to see any
reason
um why why would i object and
these or any design principles on this
so
my thoughts thank you
uh nobody else is indicating to speak oh
councillor richards go for it
uh thank you chair um i can see no
material reason why i would object to
this so i propose that we go with the
officer's recommendation and grant
thank you council richards i do agree
i'm happy to second the proposal
that we grant this application i can't i
can't find any reason not
to grant this i think it's you know that
people will always disagree about
positioning
but as far as i can see this is a good
position it's going to achieve
um some good results for the community
so uh nobody else is indicating
let's go to a roll call i'll kick us off
um the uh
has been proposed by cavs where it
should still be approved seconded by
myself
um councillor kendall four
councillor richards four councillor adam
councillor adam four councillor dixon
councillor dixon four councillor eddon
yes redden four
thank you olivia uh the committee
therefore resolves to grant application
reference
twenty slash zero zero seven one one
slash
f u l we move to item five at this point
because
no we don't move to item ten sorry
because of course we changed the running
order earlier wrong so we go to item 10
uh in which of course is in my award uh
so i will hand over now to um
councillor richard's uh incident council
richards as ward member i
have no intention of speaking on this
item
okay thank you very much councillor
kendall i will take the chair at this
point i see
councillor parry has uh indicated that
she'd like to make
a declaration council parody do you want
to do that now
thank you chair um i omitted to advise
that i am the county councillor for
wellspawn
however i'm open-minded when i come in
my views
with regard to this application
lovely thank you very much and can i
confirm with
our committee services team that we do
have the speaker online or
are they waiting in the lobby or how
where are we positioned
please yeah um fantastic
okay is that mrs pryor councillor prior
all right she's muted now okay so we are
here to
hear application twenty zero one zero
zero zero f u
l that is for the installation of a 360
technology ruggedized cctv
camera our presenting officer is stewart
flaherty stuart over to you
uh hopefully you can hear me now um
thank you
uh counsellor um i can't promise this
will be staggeringly different to my
last presentation i'm afraid but i will
uh i will try my best
um this application uh as it's been
alluded to is in wellsborne
um on a tree-lined verge between old
service road and eddington road
um here once again we see what is a
mocked up image of what the proposal
before you this evening will look like
uh on this uh grass verge area um this
camera is being mounted on an eight
metre high column
uh as signified here um
here we are in the um bilterberry
boundary
uh of wells born and signified by this
black dot
um this proposal will help to enhance
facilities and provide sizeable public
benefits
um there is a desire once again from the
local community to have these security
measures in place
and that's reflected in support from the
parish council uh chairman
your recommendation is to grant uh
subjects and conditions
as per pages 109 and 110 of your agenda
packs thank you
fabulous thank you very much stuart um
we do have uh one speaker which is
councillor prior
from wells born and walton parish
council uh councillor prior if you press
star
and six on your keypad you should be
able to unmute
yes i am unmuted fabulous welcome
to this evening's committee meeting um
you have three minutes
although don't feel obliged to use all
three of them uh whenever you're ready
please go ahead
right thank you councillor um i stated
that the parish council fully supports
this planning application
it's to be cited in a problem area in
the village the council spent a great
deal of time in consultation with the
various parties the police
watch the county council the anti-social
behaviour officer
and residents and the need for this
installation is clear
the camera will cover the areas of the
underpass the lay by
and the coppice and across the land of
the playing fields all areas of concern
these are areas where we have drug
dealing we have anti-social behavior and
we have criminal damage to property
and to the council-owned playing areas
there's a clear need which is supported
by residents who find the area
intimidating and choose far more
dangerous routes crossing the busy a429
to access the village
amenities and i would urge you to uh
grant this application
council apply that's fantastic thank you
very much down the line while i ask
members of the committee if they have
any questions for you members could you
indicate in the chat if you'd like to
ask a question
there's nothing coming forward so i will
assume that is a no to counselor pride
thank you very much
for your contribution and members do you
ha
thank you do you have members do you
have any points of clarification for our
officer
again if you could indicate in the chat
i'm seeing lots of shaking heads so i'm
going to assume that is also a no so if
we could move to the debate
i will start us off this time um i can
see no material reason why we would
refuse so i propose that we grant in
line with
the officer's recommendation councillor
jennings you have indicated to speak
when you're ready
yes i'd like to second that proposal
fantastic thank you very much councillor
eden has also seconded but we will take
councillor jennings as he was in first
um does anyone else want to speak
at this point
nope in that case we will go to the vote
i will start us off with that councillor
richards four
councillor adam counselor adam four
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
counsellor edgar councillor
council fitter councillor fitter
four councillor jennings counselor
jennings four
and cancer parry councillor parry four
that's unanimous joe
thank you very much olivia in that case
uh committee resolve to grant
application twenty zero
one zero zero zero zero f u
l i will now vacate the chair and
we'll hand the reins back over to
councillor kendall counts kendall over
to you
thank you very much councillor richards
lovely stuff
um thank you committee as well brilliant
so we move them back to our normal
i think running order for the um for the
rest of the agenda so we move now to
item five
uh this is i application reference
twenty slash zero zero
eight eight six slash f u l
um and the presenting officer on this
one is louise casey
louise chairman i think we agreed to do
970 first
um and i've got apologies that slide up
is it okay if we go with that one first
i don't see if it makes any major
difference okay so we'll go to
application reference
twenty slash zero zero nine seven zero
slash fql
over to you good stuff
can i just check that
everybody can see my screen here with
the presentation on it yes
perfect super okay so
the remaining five applications tonight
are gonna cover the proposed
installation of
six cctv cameras uh which are to be
mounted on lighting columns which
already exist
so here we've got a photo montage of
what those cameras will look like uh
when they're going to be mounted onto
the column
so the cameras are proposing three
locations across salvo
and stratford sorry um and each capita
each application will propose the same
design of camera um
and the proposals are considered to
provide a sizable public benefit
in each of the locations proposed so
um moving straight on to the first one
here 970
so it's located on pound way in southern
uh depicted here by the black dot
and here we've just got a larger scale
drawing showing where the position of
the cctv camera will be in relation to
pound
way um chairman it's recommended to
grant the application for the reasons
set out in the report and there are no
updates
thank you louise excellent and there are
no
speakers registered points of
clarification
nothing debate
let's go to the debate uh i'm happy to
propose that we approve this application
do i have a second councillor richard
has seconded
he got in there fastest um if anybody
wants to add another thing
please make it clear right now okay
everybody just wants to second it where
you can't
have a counselor just beat you to it so
um counselor kendall
four councillor richards four
council adam council adam four
councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor eden
council reading for chancellor fetter
council of fitter for councillor
jennings
councillor jennings paul and council
paris
councillor parry for unanimous chair
lovely in that case the committee
results to grant application application
reference twenty slash
zero zero nine seven zero slash ful
we move to our next application which is
this time
application twenty slash zero zero eight
eight six slash
ful louise uh presenting
yeah that's me again i'll just reshare
my screen
can we all see that now perfect
brilliant
um hopefully this one will be even
quicker so this next application here
again is in seldom but it's for two
separate cctv cameras one on parklane
the other is on watton's lane and each
of these locations are depicted on this
plan here by the red dot
both cameras are adjacent to but outside
of the conservation area
so chairman it is recommended to grant
the application for the reason set out
in the report and again there are no
updates on this application thank you
okay thank you louise excellent um
i don't think any points of
clarification i'm gonna go straight to
the debate and i'm gonna propose this
one as well do i have a second
very good counselor richard you're hot
off the mark there i think you're
copying and pasting
right so it's been proposed and seconded
let's
go to the vote i presume uh
the uh i don't know cancer kendall four
councillor richard's four councillor
adam
kelsey adam four councillor dixon
councillor dixon
four councillor edin councillor eden
iv councillor council of fitter
for councillor jennings councillor
jennings four
and councillor parry councillor parry
four
unanimous chair thank you olivia wright
the committee resolves to grant
application reference twenty slash
zero zero eight eight six slash f u l
right dale remind me if if i'm gonna get
these out of order i don't think i am so
go straight to item seven
and this is application reference twenty
slash
zero zero four eight zero slash f u
l um another camera stuart flatte
your presenting officer on this one
thank you chairman okay over to you
stuart
right hopefully uh you can all see my
screen
and hear me this time thank you chairman
um
we're now going to present three full
play applications again for cctv
equipment
mounted on street lighting columns um
members will have already just seen uh
what the design of the cameras will look
like
for your applications in selvin uh the
same design is replicated here
here we see the proposed sighting of the
cctv camera on the street lighting
column
by the red dot here we are within the
built-in area boundary of the town
uh chairman the recommendation is to
approve subject to the conditions in
your report
thank you thank you stuart there are no
speakers registered
um no points of clarification coming up
here
we move to the debate i will propose
grant on this application
nice counselor parry this is returning
to a race to open second first
councillor harry has seconded it um
let's move to the vote councillor
kendall
four councillor richards
sorry i was muted then councillor
richards four councillor adam
councillor adam four councillor dixon
gasler dixon four councillor eden
cancer edin for chancellor fetter
council of fitter for councillor
jennings councillor jennings ball
and councillor parade councillor parry
four
unanimous chair thank you olivia
excellent the committee therefore
resolves to grant
application twenty zero zero four eight
zero slash
f u l we move to item eight this is
application reference twenty slash
zero zero four eight one slash f u l
stuart jonah show us the location
thank you chairman uh yes absolutely
correct we're now here on the ships and
roads
uh within the building boundary of the
town once again uh we're in a
conservation area
uh and next to the uh greatly listed
swansea hotel
uh and the olsen obstaman hotel here on
the right uh location of the cctv is
here the red dot
um once again chairman of the
recommendations to improve thank you
thank you stuart there are no points of
clarification let's go to the debate
i will propose this one
councillor jennings rushed in there
council jennings seconded it
um i guess there's nobody else wanted to
talk about let's go straight to the uh
vote councillor kendall four councillor
richard's four councillor
councillor adam four councillor dixon
councillor dixon
for councillor eden that's reading for
cancer council of fitter for
councillor jennings councillor jennings
four and councillor barry
councillor parry four you know mr densha
excellent we're doing very very well uh
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference
slash zero zero four eight one slash f u
l
we move to our final item of the evening
this is item nine
fingers on buzzers um so you're all
doing brilliantly
this is application reference twenty
slash zero zero four
eight two slash f u l stuart
the location please
here reading waiting uh chairman thank
you um
it's uh signified here by the red dots
as you can see here this is the seven
meadows road application we are directly
abutting but entirely outside of the
uh conservation area uh but we are once
again within the builds very boundary
um chairman the recommendation is once
again to approve thank you
thank you thank you very much stuart
okay well there are no points for
clarification
i can see the chat lighting up with
people who are
so excited right um no points
clarification has been proposed by
uh councillor richards that we grant
this application it's been very quickly
seconded by councillor fitter that we
uh that we have seconded that we approve
this application as well
that's moved to the vote uh councillor
kendall four
councillor richards before councillor
adam
councillor adam for councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor edin
cancer reading for councillor
councillor fitter four councillor
jennings councillor jennings four
and councillor parry councillor parry
for
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much olivia excellent so the committee
therefore
resolves to grant application reference
twenty slash zero zero four
eight two slash f u l that was our final
application of the evening
i want to say thank you very much to all
of our offices tonight
all of our committee and all of our
excellent speakers as well
i think that brings the meeting to an
end so i declare the meeting closed
thank you very much everyone
okay